Fear. We all experience it in various forms and degrees of intensity. What is it for you?
Not living up to your expectations? Letting your family or coach down? Looking bad in
front of others? Or the feeling that you are a failure? Is it some of the above? All of
the above? Or perhaps you can add to the list your own fears? Whatever it is, you're not
alone. Fear is the great secret that every competitor is managing under the surface.
Even some of the most successful champions have admitted to feeling strong amounts of
fear during competition. It was Roger Federer in his 2009 French Open victory who said,
I was very nervous at the beginning of the set and the last game. Obviously you can imagine
how difficult that game was. It was almost unplayable for me because I was just hoping to
serve some good serves and hoping he would miss. It was that bad. The problem with fear starts
when we believe that fear is unnatural and something that we should not experience. When
this occurs we attempt to push fear away and may tell ourselves things like, oh no I'm feeling
fear again. It's really strong. This is not good. Don't focus on it. For many athletes we attempt
to hide our fear in order not to look weak in front of coaches, teammates or opponents. And as we
do this a shame around our fear can develop leading to an increase in the intensity of the fear we
feel which ultimately has a negative effect on our performance outcomes. So what can we do about it?
Remembering that everything starts with awareness we have identified five levels of how athletes
choose to think about and experience fear. We call this process moving from shame to gain. And it
all begins at level five. Fear is wrong. At this level we choose to believe fear is wrong which
creates shame where we hide and avoid the feeling of fear altogether. This causes our fear to remain
stuck and our performance can really suffer. At this level we desperately try to avoid feeling
fear which only increases the amount of fear we feel. Why? Because now we are also afraid of the
fear itself. Level four fear is normal. At this level we choose to believe fear is a very normal
part of both our competitive and daily lives accepting that all athletes experience fear. At
this level we may not like fear but we accept it and manage to do our best to focus on what we need
to do to succeed in our sport. We acknowledge that fear is just a part of our sporting journey and
it's always going to be there in some form. Level three fear is challenge. At this level we are
starting to realize that fear is not only normal but is actually an important part of the challenges
we face in both our sporting goals and life in general. According to human behaviour expert Dr
John D Martini our fear is simply the perception of an experience having more downsides than benefits.
At level three we discover that fear is not only natural but often very necessary in moving forward
to our goals. Fear is letting us know that we are facing a worthy challenge. A challenge that will
ultimately help us grow and because of this we begin to experience a mixture of excitement and
fear together. Level two fear is growth. At level two we begin to understand that in order to grow
we must expand and fear is simply our body's feedback system letting us know we are challenging
ourselves beyond what we are familiar with and without challenge there is no way we are able to
reach our sporting goals. At this level we actually start to appreciate our fear because we see the
gift it brings us over time and how fundamental fear is to our growth as athletes. At this level
we accept that fear is a part of the challenges we face and these challenges are required for us
to grow and our growth ultimately leads to our gain. Level one fear is gain. At level one we now
see that fear helps us gain the successful performance results we are seeking. We have finally
busted through the illusion that fear is something to avoid, run away from or deny and we are excited
to face it head on. The words of the great Lao Tzu start to become more real to us. There is no
greater illusion than fear. Finally we see fear in a different light and because of this our ability
to manage our fear is far more effective. This does not mean we don't feel fear but what it does
mean is that we can utilize the fear we feel more effectively instead of having it shut us down. As a
healthy appreciation of fear emerges so does our ability to maximize our sporting potential bringing
us greater levels of mental toughness and ultimately the results we are seeking. Congratulations you
have completed your overview on the five levels of fear.